unions are having a moment in the
current labor shortage after decades of
seeing both their influence and power
erode workers now have the upper hand or
at least a more solid footing when it
comes to negotiating pay and benefits
from starbucks coffee shops and apple
stores to an amazon warehouse tens of
thousands of workers across the services
industries are banding together to press
their advantage and this is just the
beginning according to venture capital
investor roy bahad company owners and
senior management need to start paying
attention he says
the business skill of the future is the
ability to lead an organized workforce
so to find out how to get there i asked
for tips from sarah nelson she heads up
the world's largest flight attendant
union what is your advice to corporate
leaders on how to
work effectively with them i i think
what's really important is that people
understand that this is a chance to have
a structure in the workplace and
actually be able to have a pipeline to
the employees and feedback and um to
have a real collaborative relationship
there that's very organized uh that you
don't have to try to make sense of
yourself
as
an executive and and so it can be a real
benefit to uh
to companies who understand how to work
with unions what do senior leaders in
management currently get wrong about
unions and how to work with unions
i think the biggest thing that they get
wrong is just the idea that they need to
fight them
this is a very very
strong narrative in wall street among
the investor world fight the unions keep
the unions out because you want to
retain control there is a strong sense
in this country right now
that people want to have unions people
want to have a voice they want to have
certainty in their workplace and so
fighting that is really a waste of money
and it's it's also it's also setting you
up as bad guy how do you build trust
with
union leaders or union reps so that
there isn't a cynicism or suspicion on
the other side so the biggest thing is
communication when there's going to be a
change in the business get a hold of the
union leaders first schedule a meeting
or
as you build that relationship sometimes
it can just be a phone call
just to advise them about what's coming
next and and get a little feedback from
them and so don't take them off guard
because when you're announcing things in
the workplace that nobody's heard about
um that
builds suspicion and distrust
as opposed to what can happen when you
are being collaborative bringing people
in using that structure of the union so
that the union leaders can say yes we
talked about this and when they're
getting questions from the employees and
actually that takes a lot of stress off
of the admin
of the company
why should ceos not be afraid of unions
particularly when there's always the
possibility of a strike everybody likes
to talk about the strike but really what
the strike is is calling the question um
so it's getting to a solution everyone
has something at risk and a strike and i
always say that a strike has to be a
part of a productive collective
bargaining relationship
because
the workers are putting something on the
line they have to really decide that the
issues that they're disagreeing with
management on are important enough for
them to risk not getting a paycheck and
going without working um and management
then has to uh recognize the risk of the
strike and so usually what that does is
it encourages people to compromise and
come to an agreement